Why, hello, you.
Welcome to Clover Grove.
I had the idea for this project.
that was kind and sincere.
I like to think that I can reach younger audiences,
because I'm goofy.
I'm silly.
And I want to maximize that and use it to our advantage
while imbuing these messages of kindness and compassion
within our episodes.
Through Apple and 9 Story, we approached Dr. Junlei Li
to be a kindness and human connection consultant.
I'm trained as a developmental psychologist.
Right now, I am a professor in early childhood at the Graduate
School of Education at Harvard University,
consulting on Hello, Jack!
The Kindness Show.
Dr. Li's participation has just been invaluable.
I wanted to also put my own unique spin on it.
Boop.
Tada!
The hummingbird has become kind of our unofficial mascot
here in Clover Grove.
We like them to indicate when moments of kindness occur.
For young children, it helps to have
this consistent visual and audio cue
to remind them of the central themes of compassion that
carries throughout the program.
It's a nice little punctuation there.
Caring heart for your beautiful performance.
The smallest gesture can really make a big difference.
Be the person you are.
And be the best version of it that you can be.
And also be kind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) Shine a light of kindness.
Start a chain of many more.
[APPLAUSE]